i mean teenage boys are the dumbest
[ __ ] walking
[Music]
i still don't laugh like that and i will
continue to plead my case like that's
the dumbest sound that can come out of a
human's mouth
let me tell you the dumbest lie jacob
wolf ever told me this one is so
ridiculously dumb
he was driving himself to school he was
a senior in high school on a tuesday so
it was 8 in the morning the school calls
at 10.
he's like jacob's late and i go okay
so he comes home and i go hey man he
goes yo
and he said schuylkill
said you were late he goes yeah i was
i go why are you late he goes oh yeah i
was driving to school i got stuck behind
a parade i was like
you had all day to come up with a lie
and that's the lie that left my mouth
[Applause]
honest like i don't know how parades
work you know what i mean like
and i asked him on a tuesday on the way
to school he was like yeah i thought it
was pretty weird too yeah
[Applause]
now
my daughter
way better liar i think it takes a
little bit of intelligence to be a good
liar you know
and so i feel like look
she this is how i knew she was gonna be
a great liar guys when she was seven
i walked in her room
i found her by herself in front of a
mirror
practicing crying what
maybe you doing that at the age of 18
or 19 or even up to 24 or 25 would make
more sense it's not right or sane
wouldn't be the one who wants to date
her i walked out of there and i turned
to my wife i go hey you know whoever
marries her is [ __ ]
[Applause]
she's developing life skills at seven
years old
you know little boys in unit seven at
seven years old little boys are
literally pushing their dicks into their
bodies
[Applause]
just to see how long it'll stay there
that's the whole game
i might try tonight for all time say
little girls are figuring out how to
take over the world
and little boys are like my dick's like
a turtle
[Applause]
and that ladies and gentlemen is why who
run the world girls just so everybody
knows and i think it's a pretty clear
pretty clear fact girls are just smarter
than guys and you know let's just leave
it at that um but thank you guys again
for watching really appreciate it make
sure you hit that subscribe button hit
the like button leave a comment hit that
notification button so you know when all
of our new stuff is dropping and coming
out but once again thank you all for
stopping by and we'll see you on the
next one
you